these violent delights have violent ends
[Music]
Westworld is back an until I am ready to
get my video out on the new episode
which will be tomorrow first before that
I want to do a video talking about my
thoughts on the first season so that
when I start doing my episode by episode
reviews of the new season people have
the opportunity to have a sense of where
I'm coming from because I didn't review
the first season as it aired I actually
sort of caught up on it a little bit
later so Westworld is a show I like a
lot
I mean it's I'm an easy sucker for this
sort of thing I like you know stories of
consciousness coming to a sense of
yourself the journey of self-discovery I
like stories of machinery and robotics
becoming self-aware
I like the themes involved in those
kinds of stories it all just lends
itself to stuff that just appeals to me
so I was I was kind of an easy lay for
this show and it's got a lot of stuff
that I like a lot I think because those
themes are things that I just like and I
don't feel like I don't know what else
to say besides just I like these themes
I'm probably gonna talk mostly about
characters here now the two major
highlights for me
at any rate are may've played by Thandie
Newton and William play by Ed Harris now
ed Harris is one of those actors who I
don't think is actually capable of
giving a bad performance I've seen him
in bad movies I've seen him in movies
were according to interviews he didn't
even want to be there you can't tell the
man puts in good work he is always good
and he's so good in this he is so driven
and so brutal in his quest for answers
and I mean he's he's in a he's in a
pursuit of a purpose and his
determination and the brutality and the
single-mindedness with which he goes
about this makes him really compelling
to me and especially since we got the
the glimpses of him younger and actually
sort of understand how it was that he
came to this place um without getting
like overly because I often feel I'm
gonna say villain he's not a
particularly nice guy I feel like with
characters like that this often over
explaining them can kind of make them
less interesting I think they gave just
enough enough of the next one inch of
RAM so I like that a lot now Fanny
Newton is Maeve first of all I I really
want to share this she's my partner Liz
Mavis her favorite character to the
point that in her mind that she and she
does not call the show Westworld she
calls it Maeve world I'm pretty sure in
her mind the the W is rotated upside
down into an M
it's Maeve world and maybe is very cool
I mean Thandie Newton I actually hadn't
seen her in anything good prior to this
like I made of she might have had
smaller roles in some things but the
main thing that I saw her and was
mission impossible to witch
but she's really good in this and she's
good even when she's in character at the
very beginning as as made as the madam
of the of the brothel and just right
from the beginning nails this character
nails the way that she understands
people the way that she interacts with
people amenities people and then
watching that same behavior allow her to
manipulate the scientists and the
technicians and then manipulate other
hosts and manipulate everything to get
what she wants and watching her desires
and her drives shift and change in the
the sense that she's willing to go
through I really enjoy I like her
relationship with Hector he's basically
they did their murder buddies with
benefits that's that's just fun and then
you've got people like Ford played by
Anthony Hopkins Anthony Hopkins he is a
guy who he never gives an uninteresting
performance or a non engaging
performance he's always captivating to
watch that doesn't always mean he gives
a great performance there are some times
especially more recently where he kind
of seems to just be there for the page
I don't feel that here I feel like he
did have a lot of layers and a lot of
nuance and you really did get the sense
of somebody who dedicated their life to
something and then as their life wound
down realized I built this dream of what
I wanted but it it's a lie it's not what
I wanted it to be what I wanted to be is
wrong and you you feel the weight of
that in him and in his performance and
you honestly you could have made a show
that was about him and about his his
transition and his coming to that
knowledge of himself and what it was he
was doing and then trying to correct it
in a very odd way but it didn't do that
instead it's more of a background
feature and that and that does work as
well Jeffrey Wright as Bernard and
Arnold in the flashbacks he he is really
good again Liz pointed this out to me he
he does confused really well which
sounds like a backhanded compliment like
he looks like he never knows what's
going on which is kind of true but
there's an intelligence or an attempt at
intelligence at those and what I mean is
through just expressions he can really
communicate somebody trying to make
sense of something but not able to put
all the pieces together like you can
just look in a space you can steal but
then you see that the gears are turning
but like there's also a wrench in the
homes of they're not not quite getting
there and I'm gonna be really curious to
see how things transition with Bernard
now that he has a self-awareness of of
himself and what he is and what's going
on I haven't talked yet about sort of
the nominal main character of the show
which is Dolores I do enjoy go she's not
my favorite not by heavy margin I do I
do enjoy doors
I do enjoy de lorises journey and I
certainly like where she ended which is
part of what makes me really excited for
the new season because I like I like
murderous Dolores ahead
a lot more than farmer's daughter let me
just say that but it really is an
interesting transition and a journey to
go with that character that we get to
have over the course of this show and I
do enjoy that and of course it the show
overall indulges in the sort of nolan
asked time displacement and having a
flashback that you don't know as a
flashback and then later on you realize
oh that was it a different time zone
whatever I say Nolan you know most
people think you know Christopher Nolan
the director but this is this is
Jonathan Nolan his brother but they've
often been writing partners and you can
tell that they both sort of gravitate
you know with him being involved in this
and Christopher Nolan not being you can
tell that they both kind of gravitate
towards similar styles of storytelling
and for the most part it works that I
have basically one major issue with the
show itself and that and that's the the
degree of the exploitative elements
because there's there's a lot of nudity
it's and it's a bit more balanced on
gender lines than a lot of HBO shows
tend to be Game of Thrones but you know
there's probably more of it than is
necessary and also the amount of times
and the degree of the sexual
exploitation of the hosts by the staff I
feel was a little overdone and and like
this is a more nitpicky thing but you
know as cool as the visual is of this
facility where basically all the walls
are clear and all the walls are glass
that made that whole element that people
are doing things they're not supposed to
be doing really hard to believe like
literally it's not even a matter of
something is somebody coming in the room
if somebody so much just comes on the
same floor as you they can see you from
across the building what you're doing
what so you know that that was a that
was a bit where the the aesthetic
clashed with the narrative but even even
beyond that which is a bit more knit
as I said it did feel like it was there
a little bit more than was necessary and
I've increasingly as I've gotten older
I've really started to develop a
distaste for more exploitative elements
of these kinds of stories I can swallow
it a little bit better than sometimes
happens because at the very least in
this case that exploitation of them does
feed into the themes of the show themes
of personhood themes of being treated as
an object and you know whether or not
you have agency or whether you're out
there whims of other people's desires so
all that so the exploitation does feed
into the themes I do still think it was
done a little bit more than was
necessary to make that point you just
kept coming up again and again and again
again so didn't didn't totally care for
that I'm hoping that gets toned down a
little bit look seeing how bloody things
got at the end of the first season I'm
hoping that like there just won't really
be room for that anymore and and then
there's one thing that I didn't dislike
in the first season but I'm a little
nervous about because it was a really
delicate balance and I I it could be
tricky to hit that sweet spot again and
that is in the discussion of the
philosophical elements because there is
a fair amount of talking usually from
characters like Ford like William you
know the adult William not adult because
they're both adult but old William man
in black Ed Harris and you know Geoffrey
right to a certain extent usually in the
flashbacks as Arnold there are lots of
more philosophical musings and talking
about the grander themes out right you
know taking the subtext and and having
it be text and it didn't work but it's a
really delicate balancing act to pull
that off and not have it just be like
beating you over the head with the ideas
that's to make a comparison there are in
some versions of ghost in the shell'
that I feel lose me with that some of
the manga did add a few points there
there are parts of ghost Michelle Santa
Loma complex was a show that I loved but
like it feels like things grind to a
halt so we can talk about all the
philosophical stuff it's a philosophical
stuff that had just been underpinnings
up to that point and it can send things
off the rails and it hasn't yet with
this show but I kind of hope that they
ease off the the sort of philosophical
monologuing a little bit and just sort
of let the characters do what they're
gonna do because the characters are
interesting in the fascinating and and
we've laid out the themes already I
don't need them you know explained to me
or detailed any further so you know
that's sort of my one lingering concern
but overall I enjoy the first season of
the show a lot and I am gonna be really
excited to see what we get in the next
season so tomorrow I'll have my review
up for the first episode of season 2 and
then I will be I'll be doing episode by
episode reviews or at least that's the
plan
obviously I've had a couple of times
where that was the plan with other shows
and it dropped off I do think I will
stick with this one though I'm so first
season of Westworld have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about if there's
all the stuff to do such as like and
subscribe and follow me on Twitter to
support me on patreon all that fun stuff
links for all those things and even more
that I didn't mention is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]